Princeton Review they released their top
ten party schools and this is based on a
survey of about a hundred thirty
thousand students at three hundred
seventy nine schools let's look at the
results Syracuse University number one
University of Iowa University of
California at Santa Barbara West
Virginia University University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign Lehigh
University Penn State University of
Wisconsin at Madison Bucknell and
University of Florida these are the big
party schools that's where everybody's
doing the drinkin and what are the what
else are the kids doing now smoking
smoking is stock in the marijuana Molly
and the mom we just had weed in my no he
just didn't know about all the I was so
stoned I did not even find out about the
other stuff so I love things like this
because first off obviously it's it's
somewhat selective and anecdotal of
course I don't know that we can really
rank them in any real way but what do
you think's going on over at the
Syracuse what's happening up there they
it's it's northern New York it's upstate
right it's really cold cold body heat
maybe I went I went to Binghamton
University was about 45 minutes away it
was not a huge party school again that
was why I was smoking all the week
because there was it because the
population like how big was the school
it so big Hamptons about 12,000 at the
time Syracuse is closer to like 40,000
afterparty 12,000 okay I would just had
this bomb it was I I was literally
getting stoned I was getting stoned and
watching CNN which is what led me party
I used to see things in wolf blitzer's
beard
I don't know University of Georgia
actually I'm from Georgia and a huge UGA
fan and my
my brother was at UGA when they were
deemed like the number one party school
in the country and of course UGA was
very unhappy with that so they started
sending out vans and just raiding bars
all like all throughout the downtown and
just right like going in and putting
like anywhere between like 20 and 30
kids in vans and takeaway anyway I get a
couch like yeah so see it be what
Syracuse beware I mean maybe that's the
one out there coming Korea yeah well
she's dead already I think put out a
statement that was like we do not strive
to be a party school that is not you
know we are academics are first so it's
like this is almost the list you don't
want to be on because then
administration's gonna crack down and
you're like I'm experienced
yeah so really you want to be on the
list of like eleven through twenty
because then nobody talks about you and
you get a lot of partying out yeah then
you're good
how much of the college experience
though is just that like it's a good
part of college you know what I mean
that you need to get I just some of that
yeah do it like I mean being an adult
you have so much responsibility and then
you get married and then you have kids
and then it's really hard to drink you
know because somebody has to get up at
6:00 a.m. with the baby so I just get it
I told my brother before he went to
college I was like sleep with as many
women as you want to drink as many beers
as you want to like have a great time
because once you get out of college the
real world starts and sometimes it is
not fun yeah I very vividly remember
being in college and all my relatives
every adult that I knew would be like
this is the best yeah yes he was we were
like stress though like I was like
stress heading for exactly the Graduate
choose between or something like you're
they thing you and just go for something
like really smart but I okay
I have a mitt I did i Dave partied every
ball you did I don't drink now and I
never have but I did a lot of trouble
right and so and and I think all the
crazy side
exactly but I liked your advice because
honestly I think that college is the
time to just get laid a lot like wear a
condom but get laid because I think that
it's it's also good experience to get
out there experience other people you
can be free it's kind of like socially
acceptable which is a bit weird like you
don't want to do that in the workplace
like you don't [ __ ] where you eat but
like you can totally [ __ ] where you go
to college like you can you know what I
mean like right get laid
have fun I was doing it I was having fun
and but you know it's like there's
certain people that getting high is more
fun than go into it and it's gonna work
oh did you also make another point a lot
of these people that are going to
colleges some of them come from really
small towns where it's like you know
like for me I always said to my brother
or my sister like you know my mom's a
superintendent of a school system my dad
you know they're part of a big family
business they're like you know just be
polite while you're there like don't get
you know wasted embarrass yourself and
have everyone in town talk about it
right and there is that that existed in
all these small town communities so when
you go to college there's an anonymity
that happened it's like nobody back home
knows what I mean and it's awesome
and you get to start over you get to
make new friends you get to be whatever
person you're trying to figure out who
you are at that time try a new identity
have fun with yeah so this was this was
a very pro party segment pretty much
think so I will bring it to one serious
thing at the end we always do these
stories about how expensive college is
becoming so we know weird and then
people that are college educated aren't
getting good jobs even anymore so is
college sort of just making itself
irrelevant because because of all the
partying in a weird way now do I sound
like an old man like it's becoming real
expensive and they're just partying and
they can't get the job I mean I think
that it's it's a bit polar to say it's
becoming irrelevant
I do have huge problems with how
expensive it is I think that there are
huge overhauls we should make and the
way that we fund colleges you know I'm
all for like the a lot of European
countries you give service to your
country and in exchange you get an
education I do think though it depends
on what you're studying I think there
are certain majors that are incredibly
necessary like there are certain things
you can't do unless you go to college
like you're not going to be good at
doctor or a lawyer yeah or I mean really
a lot of things but there are things
that you can be self-taught at and but I
do think that the college experience is
important for kind of personal
especially if you did come from a small
town especially if you did come from a
place where your parents were
overbearing where you didn't have any
individuality where you couldn't kind of
step out on your own and learn how to
fail that's I think for me one of the
most important parts about college is
learning how to fail pick yourself back
up keep going just a great point